ouais
cigare au live
11h25 nous sommes en direct bienvenue
est ce le début d'une guerre longue les
mots de jean yves le drian ministre des
affaires étrangères à propos du conflit
en en ukraine mais qu'est ce qu'une
guerre longue quelle est la situation
sur place vous en avez l'habitude on
fait un point en kart bonjour alexis
fairchild alexis adjoint du pôle actu du
figaro vous connaissez parfaitement
toutes ces données toutes ces conditions
qui se passe là-bas en ukraine et on va
évidemment faire 1 1 point ensemble
premier point je voulais aborder avec
vous c'est le dombass alexis évidemment
et je montre immédiatement cette carte
de l'ukraine pour qu'on puisse
parfaitement visualiser ce qui ce qui se
passe là bas d'abord le dombass ce qu'on
peut restituer ce que c ou c est le
conflit qui se passe depuis 2014 on fait
un point et puis après on rentre
précisément dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui là on le voit très bien sur
la carte qui était en face de vous en
faite il ya le tous les territoires en
orange
c'est là où se jouent les combats
aujourd'hui et en orange foncé c'est les
territoires séparatistes qui était
contrôlé de facto par la russie depuis
2014 alors il ya le plus à l'est les
parties des places de deux nièces qui
est lougansk
qui sont faciles et s'est laissée par
dispose ici du doigt la en rouge un peu
plus foncée c'est çà et là dessus de
yahia la crimée qui a directement été
annexées s'y rattacher parnas par là
aussi mais en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre ya une ligne grise qui
courent un tout petit peu plus alouettes
voilà si on la voit si on joue mal c'est
en fait l'intégralité du dombass être in
qui est ici voilà tâche allait s'en
lasse qu'ici c'est une région historique
et qui est constituée de deux glaces les
deux glaces aidés des régions
administratives donc de deux nièces est
lougansk est en fait depuis 2014 les
séparatistes ne contrôlez pas
l'intégralité du une bombasse seulement
une partie en gros une petite moitié est
donc là les depuis que l'invasion russe
n'est plus une invasion global de
l'ukraine mais se concentre vraiment
dans l'est l'objectif principal des
russes c'est de contrôler l'intégralité
du dombass à l'heure actuelle - ic i
contrôle quasiment tous log ans la
région l'est mais on voit qu'en revanche
admis est ce qu'ils leur manquent pas le
moins de la moitié de l'oblast des sache
où et quand elle ne
reparlera après mais là l'enjeu
principal c'est vraiment le dombass
alors ce don basse c'est là que se situe
là la principale zone de conflit depuis
quelques semaines vous me confirmer à
alexis quel pourcentage de l'armée russe
se trouvent dans cette zone du dombass
aujourd'hui si on veut dire pourcentage
de l'armée russe engagé en ukraine c'est
difficile à dire on sait que les rues
sont engagés dans cette opération
militaire spéciale comme comme il dit
environ 200 milles sommes aujourd'hui à
une grande majorité de ces deux cent
mille hommes qui sont de manière
générale dans le sud est de l'ukraine
donc dans le nom basque on peut imaginer
qu'il ya plus de cent mille fois
d'accord d'accord alors on en est depuis
la réorganisation c'est quoi il ya trois
semaines un mois oui c'est ça en fait le
point de bascule et est arrivé assez
vite dès le début du mois d'avril c'est
le moment où les russes se sont
complètement désengagée du front du nord
et qui a lancé notamment de la
biélorussie qu'elle est l'alliée de la
russie au dessus de l'ukraine ils ont
quitté la région de kiev et puis en fait
il était dans une guerre qui pour eux
n'allait nulle part celle qu'ils étaient
dans une guerre de siège d'un très grand
nombre de villes alors kiev évidemment
qu'ils n'avaient pas réussi à siéger
complètement mais aussi de chairlift ou
toutefois il revoir en bleu au nord et
puis avec arc et dont 20 alors bien sûr
on va y revenir le bleu rappelle le blog
c'est la zone où les russes se sont
retirés absolument c'est ça correspond à
l'avancé maximale des troupes russes et
puis s'ils se sont retirés donc on va
dire dès début avril est en fait il
était dans une guerre qui a calé
s'enliser yade n'y avait plus de
capacité de manoeuvre parce que prendre
à siéger des villes aussi importantes
que kiev ou kharkiv mais pour la russie
ce n était pas si vous réagissez
évidemment sur twitch sur lefigaro.fr
sur youtube vous pouvez toutes vos
questions on essaie d'y dire répondre
ensemble
de grandeur alors dites-moi voir et
comprendre que l'ukraine c'est plus
grand que la france ses 45 millions
d'habitants et donc deux cent mille
soldats pour s'emparer d'un pays c'est
extrêmement peu donc c'est possible si
on arrive à faire une attaque éclair qui
paralyse le et qui décapite hors sujet
mais le gouvernement ce qu'il semblait
avoir été le l'opération au tout départ
mais une fois que ça cette opération
échoué on était dans une guerre de
conquête classique et vous prenez pas un
pays comme l'ukraine avec deux cent
mille hommes donc c'est pour ça qu'il
céderait organisations du front vers
l'est je vais vous montrer cette cette
carte si vous me laissez le temps de la
préparer et de l'installer alexis avec
cette carte donc dans l'est il ya une
zone bien précise qui est tout
particulièrement ciblé en ce moment
c'est ce verrou donetsk 1 c'est bien ça
c'est ce que vous me dites à l'essai
alors je vais la montrer elle est ici
cette carte là on est vraiment au coeur
au coeur du dombass oui alors sauf que
le coeur du dombass comme vous dites
c'est qu'elle les deux capitales
régionales oui donc de niet est lougansk
y elles sont déjà du côté des
séparatistes
depuis 2014 qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que john yates est lougansk
historiquement c'était les deux oblast
les plus peuplés d'ukraine donc cédé aux
blast très important et qui en plus cela
on s'en rend compte assez bien avec les
zones hongrie qui sont en fait des zones
urbanisées ah ouais d'accord en
expliquant comme ça on essaye de rang
des légendes grande région qui est assez
urbanisées ça a des conséquences
importantes donc les zones grises les
régions là les villes finalement en bleu
ce sont les défis défense league
ukrainienne et en rouge les offensives
russe alors rouge foncé en bas à droite
parce que c'est une zone qui a été prise
avant le début de l'offensive dès 2014
et en os en orange plus clair ce sont
les territoires conquis depuis quelques
alors qu'est-ce qu'on marque
immédiatement fait que au niveau de la
zone orange et on fonce effet à l'état
une fois qu'ils sont ici une fille 2014
il ya énormément de défense ukrainienne
oui là alors on voit qu'il ya très peu
d'avancé à paris si pour sur cette ville
qui a pris depuis quelques jours à peine
depuis le 24 février les russes n'ont
pas tellement cherché avancées de ce
côté là sauf effectivement la ville de
pau pas sauna mais pourquoi parce que
les décès là où les défenses
ukrainiennes sont les plus importantes
donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est une sorte
de mouvement en tenailles là on le voit
alors la tenait passe aussi par le sud
on le voit pas mais elle passe surtout
par le par le nord il a on voit très
bien que le centre d' équilibre qui a
été extrêmement important c'est la ville
disent youm nord ouest ah ben on regarde
ce que je prenais la souris vous pouvez
comme ça je vais vous montrer
parfaitement cette ville ait vieux moi
il m'a souri le 1er avril c'est
effectivement un point de bascule
puisqu'on va très bien le mouvement
d'encerclement le mouvement
d'enveloppement que cherche à faire les
russes maintenant ce qu'on voit dans les
défenses ukrainienne c'est qu'il ya en
gros 2 2 centre de gravité apporteront
en fait dans le dos qui rêvent de deux
nièces et lougansk encore dans le
contrôle des ukrainiens il ya deux
chapelets de ville les oblasts voudrait
un palma les villas les au blast 2 les
aurès grisaille de news the blast le
blast biasion 2 sur la traduction il
faut encore contrôlés par les ukrainiens
il ya cette zone là avec ruby zine c'est
verdonnais ce qu'on a fait un reportage
que je voulais absolument absolument il
est ce matin dans le journal dans le
journal je vous le conseille une double
page excellente à 0 2 est avec un
reportage assez assez façon il est
évidemment le retrouver sur le site du
figaro dames et lee défense et donc ça
ça forme un premier chapelet de ville
alors c'est des villes qui chacune ne
sont pas énormes mais commune à
plusieurs ça que ça constitue un espace
urbain très important et dans les
espaces urbains il ya un avantage
clasico au défenseur donc à sept
premières zones là et puis à cette
deuxième zone avec ce l'audience
quelques amateurs ce qui est très
important puisque cram atteinte depuis
2014 comme dounia ce qui a été pris
c'est la capitale régionale de le blast
ukrainien de deniers alors pour
l'instant on voit que les russes sont
assez loin de cet incident sont encore
assez loin assez loin les hommes pour
qu'elle soit territoriale mais en tout
cas il faut prendre des zones avant
question ici ils avancent lentement cd
avancé de 1 2 3 km par jour mais là ce
qu'on peut imaginer c'est effectivement
qu'ils essayent de prendre en tenaille
les forces ukrainienne qui sont là dans
cette première partie pour
définitivement contrôler le blast de
lougansk est ensuite par ailleurs
envelopper mais c'est une
manoeuvre de tonight est beaucoup plus
vaste
slow viande qu est qu en attente mais on
n'en est pas encore et pour donner les
ordres de grandeur la bataille de du
dombass
elle regardait notre titre justement le
début d'une guerre longue et je salue
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
youtube tiens machiavel d'ailleurs qui
nous donne une information intéressant
on est aussi aidée par les par les
internautes is you met un carrefour
ferroviaire d'où son importance pour
l'approvisionnement et puis je salue
david aussi sur youtube qui n'en auriez
vous des renseignements sur combien de
temps cette guerre va durer a justement
c'est la question est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre
il jure exactement c'est vrai alexis
mais est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
revanche tourné une certitude c'est que
ça sera c'est pas une guerre qui se
compte en jours ni en sommeil je veux
dire de la guerre elle ce contrat a
minima en moi il ya déjà des experts qui
commence à a comparé la guerre d'ukraine
à la guerre en syrie il ya une guerre
longue très longue de potentiellement et
même la bataille du dombass elle-même
dur la probable mais cette bataille de
l'ambassade a finalement commencé dès
2014 c'est un prolongement ces
intervenants il y avait quand même une
grande arrêté puisque en 2015 nous
qu'après on va dire quelques mois de
combats intenses il y avait eu 10 milles
plus de dix mille morts il y avait eu
les accords de minsk qui avait été signé
entre l'ukraine et la russie et puis la
france et l'allemagne donc il ya le le
conte la guerre c'était devenu un
conflit gelé et là ça reprend de plus
belle mais ca compliqué beaucoup plus
intense qu'en 2014 en 2014 c'était un
conflit où il n'y avait pas non pas
d'aviation
oui c'est vrai que c'était presque un on
se souvient de s'être h et envoyait ses
tranchées d'un côté de l'autre on a
envoyé des unités de il y avait déjà une
guerre de chars d'artillerie mais là
l'ampleur est absolument tout autre je
salue stanislas qui est sur le figaro.fr
qui me dit que vous êtes un peu loin de
votre micro je vous laisse pour
approcher alexis un petit jeu voilà
comme ça je peux parfaitement à vous
entendre et écouter votre analyse je
vous montre donc cette carte on est dans
le coeur si je puis dire vous mais dit
non le coeur ce sont les grandes villes
mais on est dans le donbass avec ces
zones que veulent conquérir les russes
très concrètement est ce que les russes
avancent dans le bon base depuis la
réorganisation on en est ou en terme de
kilomètres en termes de villes prises
est ce que ça marche cette
réorganisation
c'est qu'ils ont complètement quitté les
alentours de kiev d'autres lieux
notamment dans le nord est ce que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne mais très
lentement parce que
le ce qui n'avait pas été prévu par les
analystes au début de la guerre on
pensait que c'était un conflit
asymétrique qui avait un géant goliath
et en face un
david une jeune indien et on se rend
compte que là on est en réalité dans un
conflit symétrique alors pour une raison
principale c'est que les russes n'ont
pas sonné la mobilisation générale donc
ils s'appuient sur leur armée
professionnelle et donc encore une fois
deux cent mille hommes ce n'est pas
énorme pour une guerre de cette ampleur
en face les ukrainiens ont sonné la
mobilisation générale donc ils ont
potentiellement plus de masse en termes
d'hommes et par ailleurs du côté des
équipements ils reçoivent énormément
d'équipement occidental est désormais
des équipements lourds et ça c'est
quelque chose dont on va parler mais par
rapport au début de la guerre les les
armements qui reçoivent les ukrainiens
ne sont plus les mêmes au début de la
guerre on se souvient c'était les
missiles portatifs qui se porte à livron
jaffelin et
stinger et cetera c'est des armes de
relativement courte portée là on est
rentré dans une autre dimension avec
notamment la dimension de l'artillerie
qui devient prépondérante
on sait que les russes ont une
traditionnellement c'est une c'est une
armée d'artillerie il ya certains
certaines personnes qui disent que c'est
principalement une armée d'artillerie
appuyée par des chars est là on le voit
très bien comme les russes ont ils ont
une forte impression leur force parce
que les ukrainiens ou un certain
avantage tactique donc les pertes aux
russes sont sont importantes et vallées
les russes la tactique sur le terrain
qui consiste à bombarder en premier et
ensuite en deuxième ils envoient les
chars mais ce ne sont pas les chars qui
vont aux chocs en premier donc c'est une
bataille d'artillerie et notamment sur
un point important
c'est la question de la portée de
l'artillerie la portée de l'artillerie
russes notamment les les automoteurs
godiche cas qui sont les alors dites moi
qu'est ce que c'est c'est grosso modo
c'est un canon seront voilà il essaie d
obus de 155 mm ils ont une portée
d'environ de 20 à 30 km donc c'est très
important parce qu il était proche de
kharkiv d'une ville va partir du moment
où vous êtes à 30 km de la ville vous
avez une la capacité de bombarder cette
ville et pourquoi les armes occidentales
sont importantes c'est que certaines
d'entre elles ont une portée supérieure
et ça évidemment c'est important puisque
ça permet aux ukrainiens de taper en
arrière des lignes russes et notamment
posté alors les appareils les les canons
m 777 américains et surtout les canons
automoteurs français qu'est l'art qui
sont les les obusiers qu'on l'a portée
la plus grande entre 40 environ 40
kilomètres et c'est assez important sur
le terrain et d'ailleurs je ne tiens il
ya
je cause qui me dit finalement est-ce
que cette guerre en ukraine n'est pas un
nouveau théâtre d'une guerre entre le
monde occidental et les russes même si
nous officiellement l'otan en tout cas
la france n'est pas officiellement
engagé et belligérants de cette guerre
indirectement oui ça veut pas dire qu'il
ya une responsabilité le narrative russe
qui consiste à dire que justement c'est
une guerre entre la russie et l'otan qui
cherchent à assiéger le la russie
il ya les deux cesser une guerre
d'ukraine et par ailleurs évidemment
c'est pas une guerre à proprement parler
puisqu'on n'est pas que les bucs aux
belligérants mais c'est l'illustration
d'un conflit plus générale effectivement
entre la russie d'un côté
et les occidentaux au sens large de
l'autre ça c'est indubitable si vous
nous rejoignez ont fait le point sur
cette guerre en ukraine on se demande si
on est en train d'entrer dans une guerre
longue avec alexis faire de chaque j'ai
plusieurs questions on va évidemment
parler de marioupol on va parler de
quartiers mais encore des petites
questions sur le dombass anonyme anonyme
n'hésitez pas à vous faites un ptit
pseudo comme ça on peut donner votre
prénom qui me demande sur lefigaro.fr
seul effort sucré nian se redéploie tel
aussi vers la le dombass depuis la zone
de kiev comme l'ont fait les russes
selon ses dires que effectivement les
les russes en se désengageant de la
région de kiev ont pu récupérer des
forces pour les redéployer dans le nom
basse mais les ukrainiens ont fait
exactement la même chose et là on
s'intéressera probablement à la zone en
bleu autour de vraies et qui va y venir
au nord et c'est aussi l'illustration de
cela circle et les forces ukrainienne il
faut savoir que dès le départ avant même
la grande bataille décisive du dombass
on estimait qu'il y avait entre 40 et
60% des forces ukrainienne qui était
dans le nom basse donc il faut pas
vraiment pas croire que parce que le
conflit est plus géolocaliser plus
localisées pardon c'est une guerre de
moindre intensité pas du tout la guerre
est tout aussi
intense que que le 24 février j'ai une
question d'yvette libert / sur youtube
qui me dit on n'entend que des jeunes
soldats russes sont déjà très malheureux
de devoir se battre qu'on leur fasse
d'ukrainiens et beaucoup déserte alors
est ce que il est vrai que l'armée russe
est en difficulté j'ai envie de dire
psychologique on entend que certains
boivent de l'alcool sont très alcoolisés
sont certains déserte est ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est confirmé ce que ce ne
sont que des rumeurs alors le fait que
les soldats russes boivent de l'alcool
je crois que c'est une vérité qui est
beaucoup plus ancienne que que l'eia que
la bataille du nom basse sur l'aspect
psychologique
il y a effectivement des indications qui
sont montré que le moral des troupes
n'est pas forcément au beau fixe
après attention à la guerre
informationnelle on a souvent beaucoup
d'informations sur l'état des forces
russes et je remarque on a très peu
d'informations sur l'état réel défense
ukrainienne donc vraiment beaucoup de
conditionnel et beaucoup de prudence je
les deux facto les russes ne se sont pas
effondrés dans le non bâti continuer à
avancer alors même que le conflit est
beaucoup plus symétrique en terme de
force numéraire ce qu'on dit depuis le
début donc ça veut dire que peut-être
que des problèmes de morale mais malgré
tout il n'y a pas d'effondrement des
trous brut vous n'êtes pas le seul à
vouloir parler de kharkiv baptiste
lambert aussi me demande j'ai vu que les
russes ont été repoussés de kharkiv est
il possible que le cours de la guerre
s'inverse dans les semaines à venir on y
vient à kharkiv parce que c'est le point
très intéressante c'est de ces derniers
jours mais avant cela un peu de teasing
je voudrais parler de marioupol
marioupol évidemment cette ville qui est
au centre de l'attention depuis depuis
des semaines alors pardon alexis jeu
peut-être c'est une question de profanes
mais je vous la pose on comprend pas
bien il resterait à les quelques
centaines de soldats terrés dans des
souterrains dans une usine à marioupol
mais il embête les russes tant qu' on
peut pas dire que marié ou pas les prix
alors en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre
qu'en dit que c'est une usine c'est plus
que les usines c'est une usine qui a la
taille d'une ville qui hésite en
kilomètres carrés donc c'est une ville
dans la ville et il ya probablement un
peu moins de 1000 soldats ukrainiens qui
sont toujours dans ce complexe
industriel des apps talent ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que azoff talent
donc déjà c'est très grand en superficie
et que par ailleurs il ya des zen de km2
sous sol sur plusieurs niveaux et et
donc
pour les russes les soldats ukrainien
qui restent à marioupol ne représente
plus un enjeu militaire sert que je ne
peux plus avoir de retournement de
situation à marioupol en revanche
prendre ce qu'il reste de mariupol ça
nécessiterait énormément de soldats et
il y aurait probalement énormément de
morts donc les russes n'ont pas
forcément d'un point de vue strictement
militaire
intérêt à lancer un grand assaut
donc en fait les russes vont se
contenter de cette situation à marioupol
alors globaux lmc que politiquement et
symboliquement ils ont pas intérêt parce
que évident évidemment ça montre qu'ils
n'ont abouti à des cellules car ils ne
tiennent pas toujours marre bien
mariupol donc c'est un camouflet est par
ailleurs ça monte ça illustre l'héroïsme
des troupes ukrainienne c'est pour ça
que depuis plusieurs jours il alterne
entre eux on les assiège et on attend le
temps entre guillemets fera son oeuvre
et puis on lance d assaut contre le
complexe industriel mais ce qui est très
clair c'est que dans des combats urbains
de cette nature l' avantage du défenseur
est telle qu'en général en tactique
militaire on dit surtout dans les villes
ça surtout dans les villes et encore
plus quand c'est en trois dimensions
quand on compte la profondeur
s'il ya un rapport de 1 à dire qu'il
faut dix attaquants pour un défense est
d'accord est ce que les russes sont
prêts à son contrat selon la nasa
sachant qu'ils ont besoin d'hommes pour
ce qui est un vrai enjeu militaire le la
bataille le reste de la bataille du
moins c'est mon mari paul langlois et
dans le donbass je vois oui mais ce
verset plus le lieu delà de la bataille
allez on remonte vers vers kharkiv donc
cette zone en bleu au nord c'est la
région de kharkiv absolument c'est parce
que l'on bhaskar qui n'a jamais été aux
mains des russes vous le confirmer il ya
eu plusieurs zones d'approchés beaucoup
voilà mais la région a été prise de thon
volaille c'est cette zone bleue c'est
terminé ils ont reculé alors ils ont
reculé sciemment comme à kiev où est-ce
qu'ils ont reculé parce qu'ils ont perdu
il ya eu une offensive ukrainienne très
efficace et et face à elle ils ont
décidé visiblement plus de deux par des
opérations de freinage de se retirer de
facto en fait on veut ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre alors première chose kharkiv
c'est la deuxième ville d'ukraine par sa
population c'est un million et demi
d'habitants c'est énorme pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée il y avait deux
grandes guerres en russie qui étaient
les deux grandes guerres de tchétchénie
l'un l'ensemble de la population
tchétchène c'est un million et demi
d'habitants donc rien que kharkiv c'est
l'équivalent de la tchétchénie première
chose deuxième chose c'est une grande
ville russophone historiquement mais ça
veut pas dire que malgré on m'a
accueilli à bras ouverts les soldats
russes on a même vu monter le c'était le
contraire
par ailleurs si une autre région que
vous l'avez dit ça n'est pas le débat
c'est la région et on voit le 2/4 le
donbass s'arrête ici hein si vous me
confirmer avec 7 à mon avis c'est ça
c'est cette frontière qui est ici
absolument voilà at il donc ici on
rentre donc ce conte dans la région
c'est qu'on voit c'est que malgré tout
les géographiquement les russes contrôle
une part non négligeable du territoire
de l'oblast de kharkiv n'est pas la
grande ville de carquefou ça alors
pourquoi les donc quand les russes ont
changé de braquet ils ont ils se sont
retirés des principaux sièges
autour des grandes villes ukrainiennes
sauf kharkiv pourquoi parce que ça leur
permettait de maintenir donc il ya trois
semaines à moins confirmés ils ont
quitté kiev notamment un peu plus honni
sophie et que ces voiles avec ça ce sont
les roms ici en bleu convoi bon il ya la
légende par dessus mais toutes ces zones
en bleu avec plusieurs villes à l'est de
kiev mais quartier ils sont restés
autour il son resto non pas pour prendre
kharkiv il n'en avait pas les moyens
n'avaient sa ferme était de maintenir la
pression notamment parce que
l'artillerie était à portée de kharkiv
est donc ça leur permettait de fixer des
troupes ukrainienne qui étaient autant
de trophées crânienne qu'il n'irait pas
dans le donbass sauf et par ailleurs
c'est leur permettez de 2 de sanctuary
faisait 7 partie 2 le blaze de kharkiv
tonnerre l'année la souris car j'aurais
franchement drame dans un éternel y voit
là voyez toute cette partie là qui est
tenu par les russes elle est importante
parce que tout elle je vous ai dit que
la bataille du nom bas c'était une
bataille
d'encerclement ou plutôt d'enveloppement
est de taille et donc la tonhalle par le
nord elle passe au dessus du dombass
donc elle passe par le blaze de kharkiv
dans toute cette zone il fallait que les
russes là sanctuarisent notamment pour
protéger leurs lignes de ravitaillement
leur ligne de soutien et donc ça ils y
tiennent énormément s'ils ont pu arriver
jusqu'à is yumkella et voulait dit que
c'était le point central c'est ce que
nous avait ce machiavel tout à l'heure
sur youtube de la manoeuvre ou bien sûr
et bien c'est précisément parce qu il
contrôle aussi cette zone est donc ce
qui se passe c'est que les les
ukrainiens ont lancé cette
contre-offensive ou précisément en
passant par là vous voyez pour affaiblir
potentiellement les zones de
ravitaillement russes qui sont en
arrière et donc en fait plutôt que
d'attaquer les russes directement dans
le donbass ils ont ils tentent eux mêmes
d'envelopper les russes qui essaient
d'enveloppés de nos vastes voilà je fais
ça tu es un complexe c'est complexe mais
l'idée c'est à peu près ça c'est vous
alors sauf que ce qu'on voit ses
claviers une rivière donne yates alors
pour ça d'ailleurs que april bien sûr
c'est le blast de dounia sq est donc
pour l'instant ce qui semblerait c'est
que les ukrainiens pour l'instant ne
sont pas allés au delà de l'arrivée donc
on peut penser que ces deux rivières va
devenir peut-être une nouvelle ligne de
démarcation entre les ukrainiens et les
russes en revanche les russes très
clairement là se retire vous voyez il ya
une grande ville en place de l heureuse
c'est vers l'europe alors j'ai lu dans
les différents papiers vous écrivez tout
sur le sur le figaro les experts qu'il y
à beaucoup de monde beaucoup de troupes
russes dans cette ville de belgorod
absolument pourquoi parce que ce sont
alors ceux qui se sont retirés de kiev
et c'est un point central du mérite de
manière générale quand vous avez une
opération avec deux cent mille hommes
vous pouvez pas et qu'ils aient surtout
va durer dans le temps des semaines des
mois les soldats peuvent pas se battre
toute la journée pendant des semaines et
des mois c'est pas possible donc il faut
évoquer des rotations des effectifs et
donc du coup il faut qu'ils les troupes
en arrière et alors ses troupes en
arrière ils sont notamment à belgorod il
ya pas mal de groupements tactiques
russes qui sont à belgorod alors
maintenant la question d'une sorte de
réserve la question c'est ces milliers
de soldats russes qui sont prêts à aller
au combat ou en préparation pour aller
au combat où est-ce qu'ils vont aller
est ce qu'ils vont aller dans le donbass
pour accélérer la bataille de masse oui
ce qu'ils vont aller au front dans la
région de kharkiv pour que les russes
maintiennent une pression dans la région
de kharkiv pour l'instant j'ai
clairement pas la réponse voilà c'est ce
que nous demande justement jacques les
ukrainiens peuvent-ils contourner les
forces russes pour prendre
car qu il alors attendez je relis les
forcer à partir de guerre compliquée
pour les prendre en tenaille oui en
groove et c'est ce qu'ils faisaient là
mais si peu mais revenir ici c'est
exactement ça on
n'a pas la réponse assez difficiles à
établir pour l'instant kharkiv donc
ville qui fut stratégique qu'il est de
moins en moins toutes ces autres grandes
villes elles sont abandonnés là pour
blandine candy stratégique en termes
politiques c'est à dire que à court
terme en tout cas vladimir poutine
probablement ne veut pas conquérir
kharkiv en revanche d'un point de vue
militaire dans le cadre de la bataille
de
du dombass mon kharkiv on l'a vu à une
importance je salue christian qui nous
rejoint sur sur lefigaro.fr tout ce qui
nous pose des questions merci à vous
alors on va continuer à avancer tiens
j'ai une question et j'en profite parce
que il ya des mouvements autour de
kharkiv et j'ai une question de vives
est à propos du général guère asimov qui
au rayon les touches alors rappelons qu'
elle générale d'hier asimov déjà c'est
le lancer le grand patron militaire d
des armées rue voilà c'est le chef
d'état major voilà voilà et lorsqu'il ya
déjà il n'y avait pas été très visible
depuis le début de l'opération militaire
spéciale
probablement parce qu'il est c'est une
manière de le sanctionner pour le pour
l'échec quand même delà de la phase 1
delà de l'acte 1 de la guerre en ukraine
qui a été un échec indubitable impose
aux militaires pour les russes donc déjà
il était peu présent et ensuite on l'a
vu enfin il était annoncé a posteriori
il ya peut-être eu dix jours maintenant
qu'il est à qu'il était allé dans le
donbass d'accord là et sauf qu'après il
ya eu des rumeurs
plus ou moins
fiables sur le fait qu'il aurait été
blessé légèrement par l'artillerie
l'ukrainienne ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les russes depuis le 24 février ont
perdu un grand nombre de généraux
alors il ya plusieurs raisons à cela la
première raison c'est que les russes ont
un énorme problème de communication de
coordination sur le terrain et donc
quand les autres ne passez pas est bien
obligé d'envoyer le général proche d'un
accord et donc ça ça fait courir un
risque
évident la deuxième raison qui est sorti
dans le new york times c'est que tout le
renseignement américain vient en appui
des ukrainiens et donc ils ont un
avantage tactique en temps réel sur le
terrain d'accord grâce à ce
renseignement et selon ses membres sont
les généraux les berlines classe on le
qui peuvent de l'agencé c'est pas le
général physiquement forcément mais si
moto2 général yahya quartier mais
quartier de l'état-major de campagne
donc il ya des véhicules reconnaissable
et donc du coup c'est ça c'est un
désavantage tactique de l'armée
ukrainienne qui a pu avec l'aide
américaine
éliminer un certain nombre de généraux
alors il ya beaucoup de généraux on a vu
la plupart des généraux c'était des
généraux deux étoiles dans les grades de
ressort
vous savez dans le il ya plusieurs types
de généraux mais ça va du général de
brigade en france qui est deux étoiles
jusqu'au 5 étoiles qui veut qu'elle
lesquels le général d'armée donc se dire
perdre un majeur général c'est pas comme
perdre un général cinq étoiles là
évidemment guerra zimov non seulement
une et cinq étoiles mais mais mais ont
baissé le chef d'état major et donc le
fait qu'ils étaient ciblés par les
ukrainiens et possiblement blessés même
légèrement ce n'est pas anecdotique et
on aura remarqué notamment que lors du
défilé dimanche du neuf mais elle
n'était pas présent et ce qui est une
chose
remarquable au sens propre de
remarquable c'est leur marque on essaye
de vous donner des informations à vous
nous faisait des questions des fois on
ne sait pas voilà on n'a pas toutes les
informations au sujet du général gueï
rasmus même si on sait qu' il y à un
point de tension à son sujet on ne sait
pas l'étape c'est la gravité de ses
blessures si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes en direct il est 11 heures 54 ont
fait le point en kart sur ce qu'il se
passe ce qu'il se passe en ukraine et on
se demande si nous sommes au début d'une
guerre longue je voudrais qu'on avance
alexis et qu'on aille dans dans le sud
avec cette zone 1 qui est prise depuis
longtemps finalement cette zone en wifi
depuis le début elle a été pris les
trois jours un casier mon père c'est
très rapide et puis là depuis quelques
semaines presque quelques mois
maintenant point mort bien on en revient
à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
que les russes en termes de masse de
soldats n'ont tout simplement pas les
moyens de mener plusieurs grandes
batailles sur différents fronts donc ils
ont solidifié ce fond et le problème
c'est que plus vous avancez non plus il
vous faut des soldats pour contrôler
les territoires que vous avez conquis
est par ailleurs plus froncé temps et
donc vos soldats sont dispersés et vous
n'avez plus assez de masse pour
évidemment et donc c'est extrêmement
classique en hommage aux militaires et
c'est arrivé aux rues c'est à dire
qu'ils ont réussi à prendre personnel en
bus à l'embouchure du nieppe le diable
c'est le grand fleuve ukrainien qui
traverse le pays ouais avoir envoyé ses
biens au cas il ya une ville à
l'embouchure qui s'appelle carson qui
est la capitale régionale
escer jusqu'ici alors ça c'est la grande
ville prise par les voilà c'est là c'est
la seule capitale régionale quatre cent
mille habitants dans la rue ça donc
c'est une grande ville ils l'ont prise
sans difficulté et ils ont pris toute la
région de kherson et la région un peu
plus à l'aise de zappos ridja
qui forment donc ce corridor ici le gie
la crimée mais en revanche n'ont pas
pris la capitale régionale 2 à pourrait
déjà qu'ils appellent ça près de gênes
qui était plus au nord ils n'ont pas
réussi à prendre la décision pris la
région qui est this absolue c'est bien
ce qui est arrivé c'est qu'ils ont pris
personne ils ont pris la centrale
nucléaire des dizaines d neruda mais en
revanche ils ont bloqué devant les deux
grandes villes demi que la leaf et
afrijet alors oui justement nicolas qui
n'ont pas les moyens militairement
actuellement d'aller au delà mêmes ya
des contre attaques peut pas parler de
contre offensive il ya des contre
attaques ukrainienne qui pour l'instant
sont juguler est contenu par les russes
mais ils peuvent pas aller au delà mais
on voit quand même le l'objectif mais
qui pour le coup est vraiment un
objectif théorique aller à long terme
étant donné son avis mais les russes
donc ont quand même avancer vers vers
l'ouest prenez là sourit alexis n'est
pas comme si on leur demanderait voilà
donc qu'ils avancent ils ont avancé vers
l'ouest et donc il pourrait vouloir
contrôler l'intégralité des bords de la
mer noire si cela arrivait du curé qui
passe ni que la leaf alors on rappelle
il ya ce fleuve qu'on voit dans la rue
l'édile méridionale c'est à dire un seul
pont pour le passé il à nicolas yves
donc reprendre la ville voilà et ensuite
il ya la grande ville d'odessa alors ça
c'est une strate ultra stratégiques à
celle de sa série au dessin quasiment
alors oui ces oublis et poutine je veux
dire pour poutine est probablement pas
au fin fond de sa tête mais on ne
reparlera mais mais pourquoi ces oubliés
parce que pour l'instant ils n'ont pas
les moyens militaires de le faire mais
il faut bien comprendre qu'un objectif
stratégique à long terme ça peut être en
contrôlant mikolaj fille odessa de
contrôler l'intégralité du sud de
l'ukraine
pour priver l'ukraine d'accès à la mer
et il ya un général russe il ya quelques
semaines maintenant alors qui est pas un
grand général russe qui était l'adjoint
du commandant du district centre voilà
ma carrière a déclaré devant des
industriels que c'était l'objectif mais
stratégique de la russie je peux être
que vous n'avez pas la réponse vous me
dites alexis d'accord les ukrainiens ont
un accès à la mer mais à quoi leur sert
tel puisqu'on voit que la mer derrière
et contrôlés par les russes n'ont alors
attention dernière ce qui est cinq murs
d'acier complètement contrôlé par les
russes c'est la mer d'azov vacarme est
refermé puisqu'il faut passer par le
pont de kertch le détroit de kertch qui
est ici d'accord d'accord il l'a c'est
l'art par les russes voient la fois les
lignes et puis contrôle que le corridor
théret schiemann de la crimée jusque
dans le nom base donc là c'est bon mais
en revanche je reste la mer noire et
alors cette mer noire elle n'est pas
contrôlée jeu on a vu souvent ces images
avec ses bateaux ces navires us au loin
au large de dessin dans des camps avec
14 à une époque il ya quand même du
commerce qui peut s'exercer moyens alors
la flotte de la mer noire russe
historiquement est assez puissante même
même si la flandre us et est pas très
moderne et des surtout il n'y a pas de
flou du craignait nos réalités d'accord
donc mais ce cas par exemple du commerce
qui se fait avec des cargos qui arrive
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a quasiment
plus surtout que le tout cette zone et
amy n'est donc en plus c'est dangereux
pour les d'accord pour les bâtiments
civils mais si vous laissez un enjeu
stratégique parce que c'est un débouché
commercial notamment pour tout le blé
ukrainien on sait que l'ukraine
et un des premiers un des premiers
exportateurs de mer noire de meubles de
blé en europe et dans le monde notamment
en afrique
et donc voilà au décès très important et
puis à part dire ce qui s'est passé
c'est que les russes avaient un peu
sous-estimé la menace navale de
l'ukraine et son diplôme ils n'ont pas
de bateau tout va bien sauf qu'en fait
les ukrainiens ont depuis plusieurs
années un c'est pas nouveau on me ont
développé un missile anti navire qui
s'appelle le messie neptune qu'elle est
un dérivé d'un ancien missile d'un
missile russe qui pèse lourd and mais un
peu modernisé et ils ont pas tellement
pris au sérieux cette menace sauf que ce
missile neptune et bien a quand même
coulé le navire amiral de la flotte
russe de la mer noire le croiseur moskva
et ça c'était un choc terrible pour les
russes on va y venir à la ce
bombardement des navires donc si vous
voulez ce qui scelle les russes ont
réalisé qu'ils n'avaient pas en réalité
complètement le contrôle de la mer noire
que l'ukraine était capable d'appliquer
ce qu'on appelle une logique de déni
d'accès c'est à dire bazire qu'en fait
les ukrainiens sont capables de dénier
aux russes
cet espace au nord de la mer noire s et
ça pour les rues c'est évidemment une
menace extrêmement importante surtout
que la portée des missiles
neptune vous voyez là vous avez
sébastopol de lille à la fin de ce ne
l'est pas lui c'est alors alors quitté
la salle pendant le bandeau mais c'est
la ville qui est en crise et là c'est la
principale choisi la gérer sainement 2
heureuse de la capitale voilà on a
intérêt à y croire et sébastopol ici et
c'est l'avancé le surtout le siège de la
de la base de ces la base principale de
la flotte russe en mer noire d'accord et
donc c'est extrêmement important et donc
de sébastopol jusqu'à odessa vous avez à
peu près 300 km et c'est à peine plus
que la portée des missiles neptune oui
de donc ça n'est pas rien d'accord voilà
je comprends ce que vous voulez dire
donc il ya aussi un enjeu en mer même
bien non je n'en mets même si il n'y a
pas de flat ukraine même s'il ya pas
toujours du crânienne et on l'a vu aussi
avec l'île aux serpents qui est il
certain vent c'est aussi le dessin alors
qu'il était l'objet d'un demi tout début
que le début or justement le croiseur
moskva avait participé à la prise de
l'île aux serpents qui était tenue à ce
moment-là parlée par les ukrainiens les
rues sont sont arrivés ont saisi lé le
lille et puis on pensait que c'était
terminé et en fait ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière s'est visiblement il ya
une opération qui a échoué dès
ukrainiens pour reprendre lille mais
malgré tout il ya eu des petits bateaux
alors c'est pas des navires mais des
petits bateaux ultra rapide raptor des
vedettes rapides russes qui ont été
tapées à la non pas par des missiles
neptune menées par des drones td2 tueur
alors je vous propose qu'on en parle
après voilà vais bien mais donc mais
c'est ça m'intéresse parce que c'est
intéressant c'est que même sur l'île de
serpent il ya un an je ne valait donc
pour les russes ils n'ont pas la
suprématie sur la sur la sur la mer
noire s'est on peut pas dire que c'est
un lac allez on revient sur sur terre
avec cette zone donc du sud ici il ya un
besoin de continuité territoriale
si je comprends bien parce que la crimée
et d'une certaine manière isolée elle
est aux mains des russes depuis 2014
mais ils peuvent passer par le pont de
kayes médine cherche est ici après je me
montre là entre à le prendre car celle
là mais c'est important de pouvoir
rejoindre
donner elle s'est finalement la russie
partenaires par la terre
et leur jeu de ligne après le ces lots
d'oeufs l'uniap qui alimente la crimée
et puis ça permet aux aussi le port de
marioupol qui est aussi un port de
commerce important que tout ce qui est
fabriqué dans dans l'extrême est de
l'ukraine que ça soit c'est un la
métallurgie le charbon etc mais aussi le
le blé va passer à marioupol et ensuite
été passé de cacher des vendus dans le
monde entier donc donc c'est un enjeu
important pour les russes mais cette
continuité a été forcément j'y viens ils
se disent certains généraux et vous
allez m'expliquer demande à ce que cette
zone soit deviennent russe
officiellement russe alors c'est pas
déjà alors qui qui qui demande ça ce qui
s'est passé c'était hier où avant-hier
il ya un des dirigeants de
l'administration de personnes donc
pro-russe donc des gens avec des
guillemets il est alors alors elle
allait lui n'était pas carson quand vous
dites il a été installé à cannes mais
installé of ice and a été fait dans les
prises par les russes dans différents
territoires contrôlés par la russie
aujourd'hui il ya des administrations
militaro civil ont été nommés par les
russes et donc une de ces personnes a
déclaré qu'elle souhaitait que l'oblast
de carson soit rattachée à la russie
sans passer par un référendum la raison
qui l'a donné c'est que les référendum
dans le donbass n'avait pas été reconnue
internationalement et donc là ça pose
une question c'est politiquement que
vont faire les russes de ces territoires
qu'ils contrôlent de ces territoires
on va dire séparatisme et avec des
guillemets c'est quand même bien sûr
l'armée russe qu'il est qui les a
conquis donc là il ya tout ce qu'il est
possible de faire il ya plusieurs
scénarios c'est soit établir des
républiques
entre guillemets indépendante mais qui
en réalité détendre et complètement
de moscou donc ça c'est le scénario des
deux républiques indépendantiste
lougansk et donne est telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui on peut imaginer
aussi de réunir toutes ces différentes
républiques qui correspond en fait aux
anciens oblast ukrainien dans un grand
territoire
formé par toute la zone que contre les
russes en ukraine et qui aurait son
indépendance et puis après il ya la
question du rattachement de tous ces
territoires
à la russie alors ça on imagine très
clairement que ce ne sera jamais
acceptée pour l'état par la communauté
internationale annonce mais la russie
pourrait la rue déclarait veut dire quoi
tout à fait le farion pour le pour le
symbole mais planté un drapeau russe sur
alors quelqu'un savait déjà le cas royal
et les drapeaux sont plantés les les
panneaux des villes sont sont enlevés
puis on les remet uniquement en russe
n'a comme le leur au delà il ya le 11
est en circulation alors pour l'instant
les deux mener sont acceptés et puis
dont cinq sens à un mois qu'il ya déjà
un moment il y aura plus que le rôle de
l'époux les salaires seront payés en
roubles et on pourra payer quand roubles
pas d'accord alors donc au delà des
combats finalement il ya déjà en a en
arrière dans les territoires de ce prix
qui n'a une politique ça parlait par la
caisse de la longue lundi à milan de
galles niveau officiel est ce que
vladimir poutine un jour va reconnaître
de quelques manières que ce soit par un
référendum ou autres le fait que ces
territoires font partie intégrante de la
fédération de russie et puis il ya le
niveau pratique réelle on peut il peut
tout à fait faire la même chose sans le
dire c'est à dire que de facto ça sera
la russie mais officiellement sa sera
pas la rue cible je salue tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent sur youtube sur twitch
sur lefigaro.fr eric notamment bonjour
bienvenue à vous on continue à parler de
ce qui se passe dans le dans le sud
comment alors oui dites moi peut-être
pour continuer sur cette question des
objectifs politique de la rigueur parce
qu on en était à pour savoir parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle il yal'histoire
aussi qui compte
et alors il ya notamment un concept qui
émerge beaucoup dans les milieux
nationalistes russes et chez les
séparatistes russe depuis 2014 alors le
kremlin ne l'emploie quasiment jamais
comme projet politique pour l'avenir
mais en revanche il l'emploie comme
réalité historique passé c'est le
concept de nouvelle russie ou
novorossiisk il faut savoir que 10 9e
donc l'ukraine était
un territoire qui faisait partie de l
empire russe est en fait pour dire les
choses très simplement il y avait là
l'ukraine historique celle de kiev au
nord qui s'appelait la petite russie et
puis les donc avait été
conquise dès le xviiie siècle et puis
plus tôt au début du 19ème tout au long
du xixème il ya eu les territoires du
sud de l'ukraine qui ont été conquis par
les russes sur l' empire ottoman et
alors tous ces territoires au sud ont
été
qualifiés de nouvelles russie et c'était
une réalité administratif d'une sangle
de province de l'empiré russe et alors
cette nouvelle russie elle allait grosso
modo du dombass compris d'accord donc
justian la moldavie ont pas et par une
ville comme ni pro et toi la danse l'a
donc si je traçant la prochaine aliments
comme ça absolument temps à grands
traits c'était voilà iata quartier de
temps mais c'était tout le tout le sud
de la russie ça s'appelait la nouvelle
russie et en dessus de l'ukraine de lui
de l'ukraine par nova voilà et et de
l'opirus elle épingle et donc les
séparatistes pro russes en 2014 on
brandit cet étendard de la de la
nouvelle russie en disant en gros on va
aller jusqu'à odessa et on va
reconstituer la nouvelle lancia le
kremlin à l'époque
n'avait pas reprises terme et toute
manière le kremlin avait acté les
accords de minsk 2 donc il n'était pas
question les mais les russes n'avaient
pas les moyens à l'époque de réaliser ce
grand projet impérial s'est massé mène
un projet impérialiste quelqu'un tout
simplement qui consisterait à
reconstituer les frontières de l'empiré
russe telle qu'elle était
au 19e siècle mais c'est un c'est un mot
qui nous faut un nom qui nous va rester
assez d'eau pour cela que m'a écrit eric
cantona la valeur sur youtube il dit ça
sent la nouveau rehaussé à ces finales
dames est ce que mes relaté là où il
faut être très précis visuel que c'est
évidemment un concept qui est dans la
tête des dirigeants russes mais en
revanche militairement long la règle a
expliqué au début ça n'est pas un
objectif de court terme possibles pour
la russie parce qu'elle n'en a pas les
moyens militairement on voit déjà
l'ampleur et les difficultés dans la
bataille du nom basse donc si vous
voulez aller au-delà jusqu'à la moldavie
et jusqu'à cette région séparatiste de
moldavie qui sait pas la transnistrie et
qui est pro russe depuis 1991 on en est
très loin mais tout ça c'est un humain
un univers idéologique nationaliste
aussi qui nous qui nous projette dans
une guerre possiblement très longue
et c'est pour ça qu'on a voit l'art et
le début d'une guerre longue j'en
profite parce que on se demande toujours
quelles sont les intentions de vladimir
poutine on a imaginé qu'il avait
l'intention de prendre toute l'ukraine
c'est ce qu'ils veulent a semblé montrer
lors des premiers jours est ce que ça
peut être un objectif à terme pour lui
de repli de se dire bon bain le sud de
l'ukraine ce serait déjà pas mal je
pense que c'est probablement l'un des
objectifs qu'il a au fin fond de sa tête
mais peut-être pas devant parce que
encore une fois c'est pas un objectif de
réaliser à court terme
sa serai peu étonnant si on lit ses
discours sur
l'histoire de l'histoire de l'ukraine on
continue à parler de l'ukraine et donc
on y vient vous en avez parlé un peu
d'être plus en plus de bombardements
ukrainien sur le territoire russe et sur
les navires russe en mer noire on
commence par justement là les navires
russes avec donc vous m'aviez dit c'est
qu'elle est le nom déjà de ce navire qui
est tombé le move à flums de voir grand
croiseur navire amiral de la flotte de
la mer noire et alors les russes la
marine russe et
souvent mise en danger par des drones et
des missiles expliqué mme way alors donc
ce qui se passe c'est que les ukrainiens
ont acheté aux turcs des drones qui
appelle des drones tv2 qui se sont
illustrés je puis dire malheureusement
en arménie qui se sont illustrés en
syrie en libye et ses cd des drones
d'attac qui peuvent tirer des des
petits missiles ou des oeuvres tout cas
des charges explosives de petite taille
et normalisé iso une portée à celle
importante de plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres et donc ses drones les
ukrainiens les utilisent énormément
contre les forces terrestres
en ukraine et ça depuis le début contre
les chars contre tout ce que vous voulez
d'accord mais en plus ce qu'on remarque
c'est que la marine ukrainienne les
utilise contre des défis cible navals
russes et ses drones ils ont été achetés
à qui elle avant la guerre où depuis
quelques décuplée savez comment c'est
juste avant la guerre d'accord en 2021
ne veut pas dire de bêtises mais choix
que ces 2 min 21 et d'ailleurs ça a été
un sujet de
d'exaspération entre entre moscou et est
et on carats de manière générale et une
sorte de duel entre entre la russie la
turquie et le drone bayraktar tv2 c'est
vraiment larmes qu'utilise la turquie
pour énerver les russes ont eu
énormément de mal à affronter ces drones
ont ciré les bombardements donc sur la
marine des bombardements aussi sur le
territoire russe mais sans jamais dire
officiellement donc que ce sont des
impliqués m'enfin c'est ce qu'assure le
fait que ce sont des attaques
ukrainiennes
n'ont
en fait jamais être sûr mais le problème
c'est que y'a vois pas qui pourrait
faire ça c'est très très difficile de
parler à lundi à l'indicatif parce que
physiquement il n'y a pas de
revendications côté
l'ukrainien la mémoire du temps et
côté russe le
discours alterne donc voilà faut il ya
en tout cas un certain nombre d'
attaques notamment contre des
raffineries etc sur tout le territoire
russe alors ça peut être des drones
quand ses proches de la frontière mais
quand c'est pas proche de la frontière
est parfois celle jusqu'en sibérie on
peut plus penser à des actions de
sabotage mêlant de qui de quoi
franchement je dis si je m'aventurais
pas là dedans on peut même imaginer ça
c'est difficile à à penser mais faut se
méfier des attaques sous faux drapeau
6,6 me secoue cherche un prétexte pour
escalader dans le conflit ça peut être
aussi un moyen donc je vois d
extrêmement extrêmement prudent on
arrive à la fin vers la fin de ce live
une question quand même sur les
munitions on a un excellent papier que
je vous conseille sur lefigaro.fr le
manque de munitions en jeu décisif de
cette guerre d'usure cette guerre longue
expliquez moi eh bien oui quand on fait
une guerre longue c'est à dire sur des
mois voire peut-être des années on n'en
sait rien malheureusement
il faut des stocks considérables de
munitions pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur là il semblerait c'est ce que
disait le colonel michel goya que les
russes utilisent jusqu'à 100000 au but
par jour cent mille c'est considérable
donc il faut des stocks énormes alors
c'est dire qu'il se sent mieux sans
mines alors d'accord les rues d'énormes
stocks d'artillerie parfois qui datent
de de l'union soviétique mais malgré
tout il faut que les usines derrière
suivent alors pour fabriquer des obus
c'est pas très compliqué je pense que
les russes y arrive il faut juste que ce
soit une économie de guerre mais ça a
priori les russes savent le faire il ya
un enjeu en revanche pour les missiles à
la de précision qui sont des missiles de
courte et moyenne portée de croisière ou
balistique les les dix candeur les
kalima et c'est
cdc des pièces qui sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à fabriquer avec des
composants électroniques qui sont
souvent importés on sait pas exactement
d'où mais enfin les rues seront beaucoup
plus de mal à les fabriquer et pour vous
donner un an d'exemple les rues jusqu'à
présent on dit on disait qu'ils
fabriquaient chaque année cent à cent
cinquante missiles
calibre par an d'accord or là il aurait
tiré déjà plus de 2000 missile de
précision au cours du conflit pour vous
donner un dandy des 2000 c'est
l'estimation qu'on avait avant le
conflit du stock total de missile de
précision de la russie il continue donc
il semble que les gens n'avaient
d'autres plus ce que c'était mais aussi
parce que j'ai eu parfois des missiles
de génération antérieure
donc voila mais on remarque qu'ils
utilisent maintenant des missiles
antinavires donc destinée à frapper des
navires qu'ils utilisent contre des
cibles terrestres ça c'est un signe que
les stocks commencent à être bas donc il
ya cet enjeu pour la russie et l'enjeu
en réalité et le est le même du côté est
du côté ukrainien
ils ont besoin de stocks de munitions
occidentale et on sait que les
puissances occidentales notamment en
europe ne brillent pas par leurs stocks
de munitions parce qu'on était dans un
dans un modèle militaire on pensait pas
seulement afin d'aider grande guerre de
haute intensité qui durerait aussi
longtemps mais pareil les ukrainiens
consomment des milliers de munitions
chaque jour il faut que les stocks
suivent j'ai plus les ordres de grandeur
en tête mais ils sont dans le tas pied
de deux meilleurs de berre donc je vous
invite à le hisser l'arrière sur le fil
en lit très facilement de rentrer tous
les pour tous les missiles jaglin
stinger pour les pour les obusiers etc
c'est un enjeu
extrêmement important
d'une guerre qui en tout cas c'est
peut-être la certitude de deux
aujourd'hui c'est une guerre qui sera
longue alexis ont fait des points
régulièrement on le sait sur sur ce qui
se passe en ukraine on va se retrouver
probablement dans l'est dans les
semaines à venir rappelez-nous pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent pour finir ce live
sur quoi vont se concentrer et dans
quelle partie de l'ukraine vont se
concentrer les les principaux conflits
les principales batailles dans les
semaines à venir alors dans les semaines
à venir ça sera le dombass le donbass et
encore le nom basse il y à la
contre-offensive de kharkiv dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure contre offensive
ukrainienne on ne sait pas jusqu'où elle
va aller on ne sait pas quelle va être
la réaction des russes qui est ce qu'ils
vont définitivement se retirer de cette
région ou essayer de contre attaquer et
puis par ailleurs on peut pas exclure
des contre attaques dans le sud de
l'ukraine qu'elle vienne des contre
attaques ukrainienne vers carson vera
porridge avait recréé viry de même qu'on
ne peut pas exclure des avancées
extrêmement localisé deux de l'armée
russe à cet endroit là mais vraiment le
coeur du conflit pour les prochaines
semaines c'est le dombass le non bâti de
daumas voilà ça continue dans le dans le
don bassin c est la dimension navale qui
va falloir observer de près vous nous
avez raconté tout ça le dombass de
réorganisation date de quand trois
semaines un mois ça moi et ses combats
qui continuent autour de ce don basse et
deux de ses villes et je vous conseille
cet article de ce matin vous pouvez
acheter le figaro évidemment avec
plusieurs plusieurs grandes villes 0 2
n'est ce qu'un c'est ça salut ma ville
la ville l'épicentre de la bataille
russe pour le dombass voilà vous pouvez
retrouver ça évidemment dans le journal
de ce matin merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis merci avec 6 faire chaque d'être
venu faire le point avec nous on se
retrouve évidemment très vite pour
continuer à parler et a expliqué de ce
qui se passe en ukraine vous suivent
évidemment l'actualité sur le site du
figaro et dans le journal à bientôt
merci